it's the Monty Hall problem imagine
you're on a game show there are three
doors behind one of which is a car
you're telling it wrong there are three
doors behind one of which is a car you
pick a door the host who knows where the
car is opens a different door showing
you there's nothing behind it now the
host asks if you'd like to choose the
other unopened door should you do it no
yes it's simple math it doesn't make any
sense to switch the prize is behind one
of two doors it's a 50/50 chance either
way it's 2/3 of you switch 1/3 if you
don't the probability locks in when you
make the choice we've been over this 8
times 7 times now you can't even do
simple additional Kevin is right you're
fired what no no I said milimeter
[Laughter]
great humor words Raymond
you know reminds me of a very
interesting article I read about human
trafficking in The New Yorker nor does
it oh the one written by David Remnick I
loved that piece from four weeks ago
where was it three weeks no four anyways
I was riveted I'm a huge New Yorker guy
I could talk about that article for
hours right necessary let's do that
right now that's do ah there they are
Kevin let's greet our guests duty calls
to be continued totes can't wait I can't
wait all I remember about that article
is the title I was hopped up on nitrous
we got to find that magazine it's got to
be in here somewhere right this place is
like a candy store for nerds
stop eating crab wrong what did the
officiants say when you got married not
much when gay marriage was legalized we
weren't sure if or when it was gonna be
struck down so speed was of the essence
do you Kevin yes and to you yes yes we
do we're married I remarked afterwards
that I wish the old ficient had been
more efficient it was very funny Kevin
still talks about it huh maybe I should
open with that zinger
keV Jake it's after midnight this had
better be about a murder no I wish look
I'm really sorry but I have to talk to
captain Holt Raymond your work life is
here please come in take off your shoes
neither of us want that good evening sir
no it's not I haven't slept because I've
been going over that stupid problem now
I finally understand Kevin's side cool
so it's all better and I never have to
hear about math again quite the opposite
I know better than ever how incorrect he
is probability doesn't kick in
throughout the teach you college-level
statistics I don't know do I have to
teach you high school statistics
throughout the teach you eighth grade
statistic do I have to teach you
seventh grade statistic do I have to
teach you now if you'll excuse me
detectives I need to leave them a slice
mail about kindergarten statistics okay
we have got to explain this thing to
captain Holt to save their relationship
and you laughed at me when I went to
that weekend long math conference
because you called it funky cats and
they're feisty steps that was the name
it was so cool it was not anyway it's
not about the math they haven't seen
each other because of the night shift I
just need a bone what gross Rosa those
are our dads I mean that's not what I
think captain dad is just my boss Wow
never mind I'm did you father the math
whatever Rosa why are you upset with me
your employees are the ones putting a
damper on the party they are acting
terrible you're the one who's been
acting terribly tonight you've been Curt
and snobby with my guests you've been
needling poor Peralta so much you
practically made him a new soup needled
him a new suit even when we're fighting
you're hilarious stop it
stop it
this wasn't going to work it never has
we should have just gone out for dinner
to a restaurant like we do every year
why did you make me invite them I made
to invite them because I like them
they're good people Santiago are you
hiding in my bathroom with a dog that
you're deathly allergic to occupied Amy
says that we should start dinner without
her then she writes whatevs : - close
paranthesis great it's much nicer just
the four of us we can really get into it
yeah let's do just that so Marcus what
orchids kini oh that's easy
oh well here are the orchids that I can
name McClarty habilidades spent Aeneid
if elects the podium a vote Ella
Romina do you know how much I love
hearing you talk about orchids great
then there's a reacts I thought I would
love to hear more about our guest row so
tell us about your family I have one you
gotta give him more Deaton at her
father's a teacher there from
Bensonhurst speaking of which have they
finished repairing the Hubble Space
Telescope yes six years ago so do you
have siblings I have two sisters I have
to leave this
no I lost my ring
do you see where we're actually it's
behind one of these three doors why
don't you pick one are you trying to
Monty Hall me it's unbelievable
I don't need Monty Hall ruining my place
of work with Monty Hall has already
ruined my home life come on sir
the math thing isn't the problem night
shifts keeping you and Kevin apart you
two just need a bone
I said you two need a bone Oh dare you
detective Diaz I am your superior
officer whoa what happens in my bedroom
detective is none of your business don't
ever speak to me like that again
I hate that dude his pen up now he knows
problem solved hello again professor
kevin cozner what do you want I'd like
to tell you about a case I solved thank
you
but just as with my home my office has a
strict no cop talk policy I figured but
the case that I've solved is the case of
the no cop talk policy there were three
things that bothered me about last night
you didn't want the nine-nine at your
party even though you've never met us
your friends immediately asked Hitchcock
and Scully if they were harassed and
there was something interesting about
that photo in your library you and the
captain were shunted off to the side I
don't think you dislike cop talk I think
you dislike cops I'm married to one I
know and I can't imagine it's been fun
watching the man you love marginalized
underappreciated and disrespected by the
NYPD because he's gay Raymond has been
put through hell by his colleagues many
of whom quite frankly look exactly like
you devastatingly handsome I'm sorry I'm
uncomfortable with emotions so yes I
decided a long time ago that just
because I love Raymond doesn't mean I
have to love the people he works with
good solve detective nice cop lingo look
I'm really sorry that we ruined your
party I'd like to make it up to you
captain thank you for joining us what's
going on a proper birthday dinner Amy
chose the restaurant captain
Oh perfect I've always wanted to come
here boy I'll pick the menu Vivian
helped Terry chose the champagne I'm
sorry about your party sir I tried to
keep them in line but I failed well
that's not your job I'm only sorry
didn't get a chance to enjoy yourself
gina has brought back all the silverware
that she stole from your house what also
this clock good heavens this isn't ours
and my contribution will be to refrain
from discussing The New Yorker for the
rest of my living days enjoy thank you
Jake
you're welcome Kevin call me keV huh oh
he told you to say that did me well you
are always playing pranks on me Raymond
just once let me be the funny one
yeah and finally it is my great pleasure
to introduce the nine-nine zone
detective Scully to serenade you Tom
from today oh I gotta hand it to you
captain
that was some ceremony it wasn't
difficult I simply said what I wish had
been said when Kevin and I got married
and I never would have heard your
hilarious efficient efficient quit
you're right I regret nothing but all
this does make me think I might enjoy a
more festive expression of our
commitment to one another are you
suggesting we hold an honest-to-goodness
wedding I didn't do elaborate we're not
the Kardashian West's after all they are
musician had a celebrity personality who
recently wedded yes yes I know
they were answers on Jeopardy I think
you mean questions captain I know you
don't want to talk about Monty Hall but
I did contact a man no need Santiago
it's all good sir fight with Kevin is
over yep because you understand the map
nope you guys you guys yep knew it
see what happened is your dad's had sex
okay Rosa
you